hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my forum readers Dawn was
asking about social media and he pulled
up an old quote of mine from the form
from 2009 where I was talking about
conversion rates of social media traffic
and I wrote in 2009 from my experience
social networking traffic Twitter
included also converts at a far lower
rate than search engine traffic and he
said is this true or do you use
something now that gives us better
returns and conversions I would still
say this is true I spend a lot of time
at social media a lot of the stuff that
I do day to day involve social media so
making these videos I'm very active on
Twitter and Facebook and Google+ now and
interest and my forums there's a lot of
social media stuff that I do and I
really enjoyed I think it's a way to
connect with my audience a little bit
more and also know you know what's
happened in my industry but in terms of
the conversion I think you're still
going to get much more conversion off of
search engine traffic and even
newsletters than you will from social
media traffic and the reason being when
somebody comes to you from a search
engine so whatever services you sell if
you sell salsa dance lessons like my
wife does when somebody texts that the
types in salsa dance classes or dance
classes they're looking for a specific
solution to a problem we have right
there looking for us for a provider to
help them with salsa classes so they're
coming with more of a buyers mindset
where when people go on Twitter or
Facebook or YouTube a lot of them are
just browsing they're there to kill time
they look for things that might interest
them really you know super short
attention span so they're looking to be
you know entertained a little bit I'm
not really looking to buy anything so
it's a lot harder to convert those guys
and to bios compared to from a search
engine when they're specifically looking
for the services or products that you
provide so I would for sure if I'm
looking
conversions for our business still focus
on the SEO side of things and driving
people from search engines because they
have a much higher intent to buy after
that I look at my newsletters I think my
newsletter converts way better than my
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube again
here you will to send a message to
somebody's inbox and you're pretty much
you know guarantee that it's going to
reach them unless unless they blocked
you off as spam or blacklisted you
that's the case you provide better
content but for the people who do like
what you do you're pretty much
guaranteed to get their attention
through an email we're with Facebook and
Twitter it's much more timely and same
with YouTube it's it's what's happening
right now and some of the half life of a
facebook books I think there's only a
couple hours and for twitter i'm sure
it's much less so unless they happen to
be on right at that moment they're not
going to see your message and so every
time you post something you're hitting a
portion of your audience where somebody
comes up for your newsletter you can
send it out they may not check their
email till the next day but they're
still going to see that message that you
have with the sale of the new promotion
that you're putting out as long as they
want to see it we're with Facebook or
Twitter if they don't check until the
next day your message is gone it's just
going to be buried for everything else
that was put up so you know the ability
to convert people is much higher my news
that our list then from Twitter or
Facebook just an example we have as of
right now around 60,000 people are our
newsletter and 105 or so thousand people
on our Twitter and I get way better
results for my newsletter list and I
would from my Twitter not that I ignore
footer I love Twitter spend a lot of
time on Twitter same thing with facebook
and youtube and and I get a lot of great
personal satisfaction and joy from using
those because I I get immediate feedback
from people and they tell me that what
I'm doing is awesome and it's changed
their lives and that makes me feel
really good makes you want to do more so
there's a lot of value there but
if I had to pick of something that I was
only focused on conversions then I would
look definitely at search engine
optimization driving search engine
traffic and building up my newsletter so
I guess we're still in 2009 don't know
if that's changed much in terms of
conversion rates but thank you feel I
questioned on I hope that helped answer
your question for those of you watching
if you liked the video please get a
thumbs up I do these videos because I I
love doing it and I love seeing the
thumbs up to come in so thank you and if
you have a question about social media
or conversions or another question for
your business feel free to leave it in
the comments below and I read every one
of them and do my best to try to respond
to everybody as well so thank you and
we'll see you on the next episode
you